hi I'm Miguel I'm I have an interest in
networks finance and obviously Python
and I'm going to bring these together
and talk to you about this so just short
by I do work in finance been working in
the financial services since a couple of
years now and but my background is in
robotics and computer science so in the
end I kind of tend to like different
things than my colleagues do and then
try to mold things differently and
sometimes i get i like networks as you
will see and i get into interesting
gothic conversations with colleagues and
they keep pushing me into trying to
figure out why it is that what i find
interesting actually work so should work
in particular i'm interested in the
applications of network theory to risk
management now please be aware i really
love not networks and i could speak
about them a very long time but i'll try
to keep it short and if you have some
questions in the meantime be i'll be
glad to be interrupted now why do I like
networks wait a minute
first of all basic criteria they give us
a way of reason and give up concepts
that are very intuitive and very formal
way of reasoning about it so I can say
intuitively Frankfurt Airport is an
international hub and how we'll have a
meeting and network theory i can say
that Ebola is a contagious disease and I
can using network theory i can use
network models to model this contagion
process and i can also say in back to
finance lehman was simply to central to
fail and what what what this is central
mean networks you can model structure
with networks and that will be very
close to grab for you it can also model
processes and networks today we're going
to focus on on on the structure we very
near the graphs and the reason why i
want to do this is because you know like
networks are a bit like the metadata for
the NSA they sound an interesting but
they give you a lot of information now
from the organizational point of view
you can look at the network structure in
this case you know some company some of
you might have been there in my just
proof what I'm what I'm what this what
is what is being shown here but they say
you they tell you a lot about what it
how it is that the organization is
working and you just have to look at the
picture and have a feeling for what it
is that how do people interact inside of
these networks inside of these
organizations from a strictly financial
point of view this was very hyped up to
two thousand eight already aggregated
data at the country level gives you an
idea of how things hang together so we
can see from this graph that you have
like a corporate free structure and this
is already some information that you get
just by plotting the graph
now in the aftermath 2008 there was a
lot of regulatory and they're still so a
lot of a regulatory activity and one of
the outcomes of this regular droid in
tivity both in the US and in Europe was
that certain derivatives contracts had
to be clear essentially what it means is
that if I'm a bank and I'm trying to do
deal with another bank and this is a
qualifying contract then I have to go to
a third party and this third party will
assume this other person's
responsibilities towards me and my
responsibilities towards this dis other
bank so in the ends is what you're doing
is you are transforming the structure
for more highly connected to a more like
hub connected kind of way this is simply
just looking at the structure now you
can you can ask yourself is this a good
change how does it affect the processes
that use this structure but today we're
not going to go into this now now the
user is and this is just copy facing
from a paper this is people have shown
that if you take if you go to a stock
exchange I look into the relationships
between counterparties these
relationships being buy and sell you can
try to see whether interesting patterns
occurred for example the patterns below
they call motifs they are a very sure
indication that maybe trading
manipulation that has occurred so again
structural information the helping and
try to give you a sense of what what is
going on inside the network now this is
a current research topic of mine I'm not
going to see much about it and what I'm
trying to look is into credit portfolios
and try to see whether dependence
between of the goose for people you have
lent or people or institutions you have
lent money to whether the connectivity
between these institutions is actually a
factor that you should model or monitor
or not and what I find very interesting
about this is just by looking at a large
portfolio of institutions that you have
lent money to and looking into equity
structure of these institutions and
plotting the relationships the equity
relationships like company a own stock
from Company B you have a sense that
there is a very connected core of
companies and the question is am I
really taking into account all the risks
when I am lending money into these
companies
so I'm speaking a lot about graphs and
networks for me graph is this
mathematical object a network is
something interesting or a graph that
embedded endowed with some context and
some meaning now in the essence you have
some vertices sorts of nodes and some
edges which are the connections between
these nodes out in the course of the
rest of this talk I'll be using a lot
the term adjacency matrix and these are
simply the weights they have to plotting
the weights or the connections between
each of the nodes in the matrix form we
speak of undirected graphs when these
mr. jason c matrix is symmetric we speak
of unweighted graphs whenever the
adjacency matrix either contain zeros or
ones it is directed when the adjacency
matrix isn't symmetric anymore that is a
being connected to B does not mean the B
is connected to a and when the
connections are can be different so you
can assign for example the weight to it
let's move away a bit from finance and
one interesting thing that I so we've
been stuck talking about structure and
the structures that I've shown you are
some things that you measure directly
from the system now it would be
interesting to see whether you can use
some implicit structure in order to get
information out of the system now if you
think of if you think of clustering so
going back to the very different
direction if you think of clustering and
if you use for example this this two
moons data set now this is there is a
clear structure to it you can see it but
if you use for example very naively if
you use the key means there's no way
that you're going to capture there
because k-means are seeing was that you
know the world has built around
centroids in this and in this space so
whenever you do the clustering even if
you know the right amount of clusters it
will find the clusters in maybe in areas
that you wouldn't be expecting now one
way to go about this is use the local
structure of data so that you see all
the points that you have any data set
and you try to see which points are near
this particular point in which points
are far away from this particular point
so near and far also being able to be
some very broad definitions it doesn't
have to be it doesn't even have to be a
metric space now in spectral clustering
you use this you take a whole distance
matrix between points it's part if I it
using some locality criterion and then
you cluster something called Allah class
in matrix the laplacian matrix is simply
the adjacency minus a diagonal
containing the degrees now the
eigenvectors of this laplacian matrix
are very very interesting and this is
what is being exploited in spectral
clustering now it's too early in the
morning still not going to go through
this but if you take the similarity
matrix from this two moons data set you
can note you can you can kind of already
see some of the structure if you use for
example something like a dendrogram
and if you use them if you use a
locality criterion on the similarity
matrix and you plot this as a graph this
is what I'm trying to do here you can
see that this structure is this is
getting very near to the original
structure they we want to have know when
we take the lymph a thing of this one
when we take when we take the Laplace
king of this one and we do the eigen
vector analysis it turns out that those
low value eigen vectors give you
actually the low value eigen values give
you the eigenvectors that would be like
to separate these areas so for example
I'm if we know that it's too but let's
just make it not work so well with three
clusters then you get at least one of
the moon's pretty well recognized so
let's let's go back to finance can we
use something from this locality
analysis can we infer structure from
let's say correlation matrix now
correlation matrix then covariance is a
very very usual way of modeling time
series data in the essence what you do
easily take a time series you can take a
given window and you compare each of the
time series by a correlation measure and
then you put this together he put this
in the matrix form and you get the
correlation much
now this correlation is computing by
using the returns the returns are the
ratios between the end of the prices of
given assets you usually normalize them
compare the core wire the the pairwise
correlation this being the pearson
correlations and when you do this over
time when you get this correlation
matrix over time and then something
interesting happens if we do the eigen
vector analysis of this correlation
matrix put it a bit and then you plot
each of the eigen values over time the
blue one here being the strongest the
first eigenvalue you see that whenever
something interesting happens and
interesting might be endogenous or
exogenous to system then you get some
spikes right example lehman you get a
huge spike the housing bubble even some
people some important people talking at
a press conference by dragging a PCB
that whatever it takes the downgrade
fukushima so this is this is really
interesting information now people are
using this for example to make something
called risk on risk off so whenever the
value first eigen vectors is first eigen
values rising you call this as a risk I
don't remember risk-off not risk on so
everybody is kind of synchronizing
everybody is doing the same thing so the
first eigenvector is very strong that
means that either something as other
things are very correlated or very
anti-correlated so kind of everything is
moving either in the same direction on
the opposite direction whereas when you
have a risk of face you have more
diversification and then the first
eigenvalue just
drops over time now this is a very
interesting from from a purely
descriptive perspective this is a
interesting but the question is can we
do something with this information know
what I'm going to talk about is I'm
going to do more of a talking about a
paper it's not my work but I find it
very interesting and I've been trying to
replicate parts of its work and what
they use is actually what they do is
actually trying to use this information
in order to do in from a to do to do an
asset allocation decision that is they
try to use this information in order to
invest and their whole reasoning is a
graph based reasoning and that's why we
will give up here today and they're
using basically the notion of centrality
too cold diversification so this is this
is a paper it's a nature baby it's very
very very cool paper so what did he do
for each point in time they look at a
given set of correlations from a fixed
set of assets from the past build the
correlation matrix and then select from
these from this pool of assets select a
given subset of assets if you're for
example you're based on trying to trade
on the for example SMP 500 you're not
going to put 500 orders every time
you're not going to reshape your
portfolio every time so you you you want
to keep the number of assets that you
try and imagine that actually very short
so that the the costs associated with
the management of your portfolio are
reduced now there's several current ways
of our usual ways of doing this for
example one of them is using sector and
ask if you know that you have a large
pool of assets and you have some
financials you have some
masuda calls you have some automobile
industry you have some some web
companies you're not going to put
everything in the web companies not
going to put everything in your car
makers you're going to try to diversify
a bit so you're using a prior
information in order to in order to make
a deformity incision now people have
shown in time is that if you take the
correlation matrix if you do a cluster
analysis on this correlation matrix then
what you get sometimes as clusters that
are very similar to this sector
information so and if you do a graph
analysis of this correlation matrix then
you get also clusters that are very
similar to the to the to the information
that you already know about the category
so this is another hint that the
structure of the correlation matrix
might have some info some interesting
information and you're really using it
so the back to the methodology so they
for each point in time they look at the
correlation matrix and try to decide in
which assets am I going to try and
invest now they have a different set of
methodologies and then they evaluate
them the portfolio's that they've built
with these acid baskets over time
sorry now as I said before the
correlation matrix you need some
structure in order to interpret the
matrix itself so if you just plot it
using the lexicographic order of the
particular names of the assets it's
going to be difficult to read it's
difficult to see something out of it if
you use a dendrogram then you start
seeing some patrons now the dendrogram
is nothing else but a tree right there's
a tree structure so the tree is a subset
of a graph there there I am again there
am i again making the connections to the
grubs and then the question arises do I
need every single data point in the
correlation matrix do I need to model
and if you look at the tree then the
answer is obviously known now which
criteria should i use in order to remove
information or removes data points from
my relational matrix to specify the my
correlation matrix so that it so that I
get at some parsimonious model
parsimonious representation others now
there's a whole set of criteria you can
use you can use a threshold-based you
can use a like the probability that some
correlation occurs out of the random you
can use map random matrix theory but you
can also use geometric criteria one of
the genetic criteria is for example the
minimum spanning tree now the minimum
spanning tree tries to go through all
the vertices to all through all the
assets in a trailer by structure and
trying to minimize the whole distance so
the sum of the weights of the edges not
what we have here is the minimum
spanning tree of the correlation matrix
that I've shown
and you find some sector based
information here as represent by the
colors so you see that they do try to
stick together things that are similar
however you throw a lot of information
out when you do the minimum spanning
tree may we need more information so now
what the the people in the paper have
done is use another way of constructing
a graph out of the correlation matrix
it's called the planet maximally field
trick reps and it essentially goes
usually something uses something called
the planarity criteria which is simply a
yes or no test and like if yes this
isn't this means that the graph can be
embedded into a sphere without edges
being crossed so this is a plane genetic
criteria now what what they do is they
take the map the similarity matrix they
go from the high similarity to the
lowest similarity and try to add edges
to the graph if the graph is planet then
you keep the edge if the graph is not
tired then you throw the edge away what
comes out is a graph that has the
minimum spanning tree in itself but also
has many more connections there now what
they use is this way of building the
graph so this is a picture from the
paper and a reason about what is central
and what is horrific now why would you
do this no the idea is if something is
central then probably it is similar to a
lot of things nearby whereas if
something is on the borders of your
graphs
sure then probably it is farther away
from the purely similar similarity
perspective from most of the other
points in the graph so what they do is
they use as they rank the whole set of
notes based on the celerity and they
take the 30 most 30 less central notes
in it try to build acid baskets from
this so they have correlation matrix
they transform the correlation matrix
into a graph and then they build the
centrality measure which tells them this
is in the middle or this as in the
periphery and they say that whatever is
if i take assets that are in the
periphery that I'm probably more
diversified
and I find the results very interesting
know if you take sets of assets using
peripheral assets which would be the red
squares or you use a purely based
performance criteria which is the
triangle the pink triangle or if you go
to the center of the graph or you peak
summit random then you get different in
average you get different portfolios
what is interesting there is the four
equally weighted portfolios the
periphery the peripheral assets the
outperform the market portfolio which is
a good sign and they all perform every
other now at the same time they have
figured out that the performance of the
assets isn't correlated to the
centrality
so using equally weighted portfolios
they perform pretty well when they put
some optimization on top of it then the
market portfolio marks portfolio being
every 500 acids it's only here as a
control for locus for small values of
the four small sizes of the basket it
outperforms the the peripheral portfolio
is but even for but for larger asset
baskets then the peripheral portfolio is
try and tend to outperform it now what
is very interesting as well is that the
weight given by the optimization for the
peripheral peripheral portfolios they
are pretty small and this is something
that is usually addressed in the
optimization in the optimization of
portfolio management and this is a very
very interesting property for portfolio
managers now at the same time the
central portfolios tend to be less
perform again even if there is no
correlation between centrality and
performance of the individual assets
now what I like for you to take home as
a message is first structure is
important and network theory helps you
deal with the structure it helps you
identify groups in your network and it
gives you precise definitions of what is
essential and this we have seen this is
information that might be useful even in
the case of financial modeling even in
the case of investment there is lots of
structure to be seen in finance now for
example when I when I when I look at
yesterday's talk on this size of banks
now this this is it sort of this is very
obviously very valid research but it's
not the only way of measuring well
measuring in size of banks is one thing
measuring the importance of banks is
another thing and in or intimately
importance of banks we both need to
measure the size and the place of the
bank's inside of the of the of the
system and so you need to do a
structural analysis so additionally even
if you don't have the structure being
given to you by the problem definition
you can try to infer the structure by
using local massive methods for example
using these minimum spanning trees is
these planner graphs or for example
using spectral clustering and that's it
or persons open for questions thank
you